let me uh read something else aoc was
involved in this week which is her
series of tweets about abortion because
that's the big story that's happened in
texas of course but all the country is
watching this because this has always
been i think the great motivating issue
in elections in the last many decades
for women i mean we've often heard the
the phrase
you know if men could get pregnant
well aoc says the gutting of roe versus
wade imperils every menstruating person
in the u.s
i would have thought maybe just saying
women but okay i'm i'm willing to always
listen
uh she said just one reason roe isn't a
woman's issue
people who aren't women can menstruate
two
duh
trans two-spirit and nine binary people
have always existed will always exist
people can stay mad at that or grow up
um i guess they menstruate or i don't
know trans men have uteruses trans men
menstruate trans men can't hold men do
get pregnant wait wait all trans men
have uteruses well trans men are
biologically female and they've
transitioned to male okay and not all
trans people get bottom surgery right
and not all trans men get hysterectomies
and there are trans men who keep their
uteruses and want to become parents and
will become pregnant so trans men do
menstruate can't get pregnant if they're
on testosterone it suppresses
menstruation
uh and they'll go off testosterone if
they want to get pregnant but that is
something that can impact a transmen can
be raped and sometimes are raped by cis
people who are angry at them for being
trans and can get pregnant and need an
abortion just like a woman right victim
could mean an abortion okay i'm just
maybe what she should have said is
basically abortion is an issue who
affects everyone who has sex
let's make it inclusive and not true oh
she did
every person who engages in sex but my
question is political it's about this
has always been a woman's issue and when
you say
uh this is not a woman's issue
i'm wondering if that's the best i i
it's important that the the two-spirit
vote i'm sure is very important um i'm
not mocking two-spirit i this the first
time i heard it i mean maybe what i'm
saying is you know maybe if the tone of
this wasn't like
you morons who don't know that that men
can menstruate and what two-spirit is
catch up that's why people hate i think
what you're saying is let's get beyond
the tribalism because the problem with
tribalism is that these people get
affiliated almost no matter what to an
opinion and a standpoint
i i have to say like i i completely
agree with aoc that trans two-spirit
non-binary people have always existed
everybody needs to get over it forty
years ago gays and lesbians were
teaching people are just learning about
it right and we shouldn't be so scolding
in tone but i disagree that abortion
isn't a woman's issue or that we
shouldn't describe it as one the left
talks about voter suppression laws that
make it harder to vote as racist they
are racist in their intent they target
black voters particularly and we talk
about that as a racial issue even though
some white people aren't going to be
able to vote don't have voter id might
have a harder time voting we don't say
don't talk about voter suppression like
it's about race because some white
people and i think we can do the same
we can walk the same line on abortion
yes it is
it's misogynistic patriarchal it targets
women it's about controlling women's
bodies
it is going to impact some trans to
spirit and non-binary people who might
need access to abortion too but the
intent of the law targeting abortion
like the intent of the laws targeting
voter suppression that is racist even
though some white people are gonna get
over too the intent of
anti-choice anti-abortion laws what's
going on texas is to target women and
it's going to impact some trans men too
okay
maybe
you know
help us along explain don't have this
attitude like the part of the country
that isn't completely caught up with
this
is just moronic and i can't even bear to
deal with you grow up
it's just it's just first of all it's
just bad politics it is it's bad it's
these aren't i don't know if she thinks
she's only only republicans
are in that camp who don't know what two
spirit is
but i think a lot of people are just
learning about something but this stuff
and it's new let's not pretend all of
this is having this conversation now
about it because of what she said which
was a little scolding and probably
unhelpful but now we're having a
reasonable conversation about it and
more people who are watching and
listening are finding out about what two
spirit is and what two spirit means
what does it mean
native americans described people who
were gender non-conforming as having two
spirits a male spirit and a female
spirit in one body one person right and
it was sort of
what they what native americans used to
to mean what we use trans to mean that's
why you see it lumped together with
trans to spirit non-binary that's what
two spirit is it's a native american
okay but i'm a fairly well-informed
person and i just learned it but you
just yeah but you were open to learning
i mean and you learned it i am open to
learning but you learned it because of
what ao's east aoc that's not the way to
do it i agree i wish the left could take
the example of obama in 2007. what
obama's michelle and barack both did was
they never got angry in public and they
had every right to be angry all the time
absolutely but it would have cost him
yes he needed never took the bait
looking for an excuse to vote against
him because he wanted to get the power
to benefit the lives of people he wanted
to change so he never got angry in
public and it was strategic and
political should a black man be able to
get angry in public and get elected
president absolutely right can one no
right and obama knew that right and so
the lesson here for the left is like can
we be a little bit more like obama about
our rhetoric about our positioning to
bring along the people who
may not know what two spirit means yet
but we still need their votes so don't
flip them off while you're telling them
what two spirit means
and be less tribal i mean if you were to
put the founding fathers in a time
capsule and bring them to the modern era
i think they're pretty pretty shocked
that the united states
[Laughter]
straight away for some very good reasons
actually too yeah but exactly but i mean
you know they didn't envisage an america
where everyone was as tribal as this
they tried to build in checks and
balances to avoid that and going back to
that spirit of actually having empathy
and trying to reach out to people who
shock right they have a different point
of view from you may have a slightly
different
country
lots of people who are not like you and
just to insist that you come over and be
exactly like i say you are immediately
that's not going to work 101
anthropology is actually recognizing
that just because it's your worldview it
doesn't mean that you can assume it
should be everyone else's right it's
about trying to listen to somebody else
for change and actually recognizing the
art of trying to listen to another point
of view doesn't just give you empathy
for others it actually teaches you about
yourself too because there's this great
chinese proverb a fish can't see water
unless you jump out of your fishbowl and
go and swim in different water for a bit
and by golly after cover 19 lockdown
where we've all been locked down with
our own tribe our own little pod people
just like us there is a desperate need
right now to jump out and go and swim in
some other water and try shock horror
and talk to someone who might actually
be from a different party oh i could not
agree more
and don't talk politics with them just
talk yeah
you